l'ondé de choc jean marie le pen sa
présence au second tour mais la france a
la une des journaux du monde entier à
gauche comme à droite un front
républicain est en train de se
constituer les verts le pc le ps l'udf
et démocratie libérale appelle
officiellement à voter pour jacques
chirac
et puis les manifestations continuent
trente mille lycéens et étudiants
rassemblés aujourd'hui dans les rues
d'une vingtaine de villes de france
comment expliquer cette percée de jean
marie le pen trois questions à pascal
perrineau professeur en sciences
politiques il nous rejoindra tout à
l'heure à droite jacques chirac a reçu
aujourd'hui françois bayrou et alain
madelin ils rencontrent en ce moment
l'ensemble des parlementaires de droite
objectif la création d'un grand parti du
président invités michèle alliot-marie
présidente du rpr qui nous rejoindra
elle aussi tout à l'heure la à cocher
saône et lionel jospin hors jeu n'a fait
qu'une brève apparition au bureau
national du parti socialiste c'est
françois hollande qui est chargé de
mener campagne pour les législatives
il est avec nous également françois
hollande bonsoir et puis on reviendra
enfin sur la débâcle du parti communiste
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
c'est une édition spéciale que nous
consacrons ce soir bien sûr aux
résultats du premier tour de la
présidentielle avec de nombreux
reportages et invités
vous en connaissez le résultat a
rappelons le en ce qui concerne les deux
premiers ils sont quasiment définitive c
score 19 88% des voix pour jacques
chirac 16,86 % pour jean marie le pen
jean-marie le pen dont la présence au
second tour a pris tout le monde de
court
il est maintenant au centre du jeu les
24 heures qui ont fait trembler la scène
politique française reportage michaël
darmon philippe peyroux
il s'est toujours plaint de ne pas avoir
les honneurs des médias mais depuis hier
soir les journalistes du monde entier
veulent parler à jean marie le pen ce
qui n'est pas toujours simple pour lui
les grognards de l'open se retrouve à
saint cloud pour la première fois dans
son histoire le front national est
qualifié pour le duel final dans une
élection présidentielle je ne parle pas
de revanche mais que moi je me bats
depuis 45 ans côté de recruter de jean
marc à l'open ayant été soldat en
indochine ayant été salta en algérie je
ne pouvais pas ne pas penser à tous les
gars qui pensaient que je pensais qu'ils
sont morts aujourd'hui bureau exécutif
bureau politique tout l'organigramme des
fl et mobiliser pour mettre sur pied les
roches amitié et arrêter la stratégie
aller simple ce sera le pen seule contre
couvre à droite et gauche communient
dans un front réputé républicain qui met
aujourd'hui opposés
c'est un véritable aveu du pacte secret
qui unit les politiciens corrompus et
prébendiers du système chirac et l'homme
c'est l'homme des clans contre le pen
l'homme des français libres
ce combat est celui de goliath contre
david
et pourtant david la terre à ces comités
le président mon cher vous êtes heureuse
vous allez l'avoir à se dire on va
l'avoir nominé au téléphone les messages
prolonge la clameur qui a jailli
hier à 20 heures quand les flux g25 lui
est devenu l'épicentre d'un tremblement
de terre politique
que des facilités des présents c'est le
plus beau jour de ma vie
c'est le début de la renaissance de la
france ça fait 22 ans que je me bats
pour visiter on arrive en une demi-heure
plus tôt jean-marie le pen se faisait
confirmer les estimations
et ça marche
ce n'est que plus tard dans la soirée
qu'il se présentera devant ses militants
de
une nuit de fête commence au siège du
front national le parti qui vient de
faire exploser la vie politique
française
à
michaël darmon qu'on retrouve en direct
au quartier général de saint cloud
comment prépare-t-on ce deuxième tour
michaël est ce que c'est une vraie
campagne de deuxième tour qui s'amorce
alors écouter ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que la question du style de la campagne
deuxième tour a été abordée très tôt
dans une réunion de la direction du
front national dès le 28 février et ce
qui a été confirmé ce matin c'est le
principe de trois grands meetings sur
marseille lyon et paris pour le premier
mais l'entourage de jean marie le pen a
plaidé pour limiter le nombre de
déplacements afin de limiter également
le nombre la tenue de
contre-manifestations il s'agit nous
explique-t-on en fait de ne pas ternir
une campagne d'image jean marie le pen
qui pourraient démarrer dès la semaine
prochaine
merci à michael officiellement jean
marie le pen n'a reçu le soutien que de
bruno mégret le vote le pen causes
conséquences réaction histoire réaction
français en europe et on va y revenir
très longuement dans un court instant
avec notamment marie france stirbois
député européen et pascal perrineau
professeur de sciences politiques
d'abord on poursuit avec l'actualité de
ce lendemain de vote
pas de temps mort pour jacques chirac
voici pour commencer la carte de france
du vote chirac le président candidat est
arrivé en tête dans 12 régions sur 22
pour lui l'essentiel est fait il semble
désormais assuré de l'emporter au second
tour
mais dès aujourd'hui il a rencontré
françois bayrou et alain madelin est en
ce moment même l'ensemble des
parlementaires de droite reportage
philippe boisserie edwards père jacques
chirac n'aura pas tardé pour sonner la
mobilisation moins de 24 heures après le
résultats dévastateurs du premier tour
il a réuni ses troupes
un défilé de parlementaires du rpr de
l'udf de dld premier ministrable même
les principaux soutiens de françois
bayrou et d'alain madelin sont là pour
entendre à jacques chirac plaidé pour la
construction d'un grand mouvement de
politique moderne direct
des applaudissements nourris j'ai senti
rassemblés par le moteur essence et
rassembler tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans ce message et qu'ils
ont envie que la majorité issue de
l'élection législative puisse réussir
car je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans la
situation de notre pays nous n'avons pas
le droit à l'erreur car l'apparition
hier à 20h de l'adversaire de jacques
chirac a tout bouleversé
à commencer par les militants chiraquien
partagé entre applaudissements et
consternation en jeu suivante le
confronterons boîte à rythmes et bas
parce qu'on a bien joué entre chirac et
le pen je comprends c'est chira sport un
désarroi exprimées par des huées à
chaque apparition de jean marie le pen
sur les écrans
et des sifflets pour lionel jospin seul
baume au coeur à 23h l'appel au
rassemblement de leur président la
france ne peut attendre voici venu le
temps du sursaut démocratique
je m'appelle aux françaises et aux
français
à chacune et à chacun d'entre vous parce
que la démocratie c'est le bien le plus
précieux
ce matin c'est un jacques chirac muet
qui est arrivée à son qg
pas un mot et surtout pas sur un
possible débat avec jean marie le pen
la stratégie face à l'extrême droite
n'occultait pas les débats au sein de la
droite deux adversaires d'hier c'était
même invité sur le coup dès midi à la
sortie
alain madelin et françois bayrou n'avait
pas tout à fait le même point de vue il
y à vraiment la nécessité de faire d'une
hausse
et de sortir l'opposition de cet
enfermement au centre qui a provoqué la
montée des extrêmes françois bayrou
plaide lui pour un modèle inédit ouvert
largement plus largement qu'au travers
des frontières habituelles
en tout cas c'est ce que je crois qu'il
faut faire la politique nouveau
ouvertures nécessaires pour reconstruire
un pays un modèle assez éloignée du
grand mouvement de droite prônée par
jacques chirac alors à l'hôtel
intercontinental où se tient cette
réunion avec les parlementaires entre ou
véronique sainte olive véronique qu'est
ce qu'on va effectivement vers ce parti
du président à vie de la réunion est
terminée jacques chirac est reparti avec
lui et très très nombreux élus qui
étaient venus du rpr mais aussi de l'udf
et de dl
alors jacques chirac leur a dit la chose
suivante il sait il sail est quasiment
certain qu'il sera élu au deuxième tour
l'important pour lui c'est de se doter
maintenant d'une majorité cohérente et
solide à l'assemblée nationale et pour
ça donc il a il leur a dit qu'il
souhaitait qui est un candidat unique de
la droite unie dans chaque
circonscription
alors est-ce qu'on va vers un parti
unique du président est bien vrai dire
ça y ressemble on ne parle plus de u2
lui-même vous savez qu'il y avait
provoqué beaucoup de turbulences mais
effectivement comme l'a dit philippe
boisserie on parle d'un grand mouvement
où toutes les sensibilités seraient
représentés et on sait que les
centristes seront particulièrement
attentifs à cela
enfin jacques chirac a expliqué tout à
l'heure à tous les parlementaires qu'il
avait besoin de cette solide de cette
solide majorité à l'assemblée pour
engager les réformes que les français
attendent
à propos de la sécurité mais aussi bien
sûr des emplois des jeunes ou encore des
retraites
merci véronique rappelons-le a encore le
score quasi définitif maintenant de
françois bayrou et alain madelin 6,84 %
pour le candidat udf qui arrive en
quatrième position 3 91 pour alain
madelin dans un instant pour évoquer
cette situation à droite nous serons en
duplex avec michèle alliot marie
d'abord la journée à gauche et plus
précisément au parti socialiste encore
sous le coup de l'élimination surprise
de lionel jospin et de l'annnonce de son
retrait de la vie politique
lionel jospin qui a réalisé un score de
16,18 % tout s'est donc joué à deux cent
mille voix près avec jean marie le pen
16,18 soit 7 points de moins qu'en 1995
on l'a appris tout à l'heure c'est
françois hollande qui reprendra le
flambeau pour mener la campagne des
législatives qu'elle vit un bear fabrice
dujardin sourires et accolades malgré
tout malgré la défaite
lionel jospin ce matin dans la cour de
l'hôtel matignon
c'est l'une des dernières fois que l'on
verra cette image dans quinze jours
comme il l'a annoncé le premier ministre
aura quitté la scène politique paraît
rue de solférino au siège du ps au même
moment il ya les visages qui en 18 ans
celui de jean glavany le directeur de
cette campagne qui se termine si mal
ceux des proches collaborateurs de
lionel jospin mais visage enfin des
futurs anciens ministres qui en gros sur
le coeur
ceux qui sont allés à la pêche qui ont
fait la fine bouche à qui il aurait
fallu un petit peu plus de ceci un petit
peu moins que cela et ben voilà le
résultat
voilà maintenant nous voilà aux dents
dans l'eau jusque là je suis surpris du
nombre de coups de fil que je reçois de
la part de gens qui me disent mon pensé
venir au deuxième tour on voulait
envoyer un message
aujourd'hui ils se rendent compte que ce
message est en train d'arriver en poste
restante dans les boîtes aux lettres de
chirac et le pen chirac le pen le duel
et le choix auquel il faut bien se
résoudre pour les socialistes à contre
coeur mais sans ambiguïté
il est clair qu'il faut faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et voter jacques chirac
il faut que tous les démocrates et les
républicains veulent jacques chirac il
faut pas se réveiller après coup comme
hier soir et pour que ce soit encore
plus claire françois hollande désormais
seul patron à bord au ps donne la
consigne officielle
nous savons que jacques chirac est notre
adversaire dans le cercle de la
démocratie mais que jean marie le pen
est un danger pour la république ce
matin lionel jospin est arrivé le
dernier au bureau national du ps il n'y
est pas resté très longtemps le temps
d'une déclaration en forme d'adieu à ses
amis je ne serai plus désormais qu'un
simple militant leur dit-il avant de
repartir dans la rue de solférino
quelques sympathisants voulait attendre
gagner le jospin pour l'applaudir
là encore dans la deuxième partie de ce
journal on reviendra plus en détail sur
les raisons de cette déroute mauvaise
campagne dispersion des voix
et puis françois hollande sera donc avec
nous autre effet de cette percée de jean
marie le pen dès hier soir plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes des
jeunes pour la plupart lycéens ou
étudiants sont descendus dans la rue
pour dire leur hostilité au front
national
place de la bastille ici à paris ils
étaient encore plusieurs milliers après
minuit on a signalé ensuite des
incidents échappe aux chats échafaudage
démonter vitrines brisées affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre des
manifestations qui se sont poursuivies
aujourd'hui un peu partout en france
alban nicosie frédéric faure filon 16 17
ans trop jeune pour voter mais pas pour
se faire entendre à poitiers ville de
charles martel dans l'extrême droite se
réclament parfois 600 lycéens ont
improvisé un cortège pour exprimer leur
inquiétude normale au deuxième tour je
suis désolé c
quelque chose qui ne leur est pas arrivé
vraiment ils voient ça cesse donc c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on est tous là et
on va pas arrêter comme ça avec tout
d'imaginer le pen est profond
debré stanis de la rochelle à besançon
on estime à plus de trente mille le
nombre total de manifestants
gros plan sur caen avec la rencontre à
la faculté d'étudiants et de lycéens
pour une séance d'autocritique
c'est à dire que 40 % 18 25 ans ont
laissé des gens qu'on appelle un succès
parce qu'au jour national électoral se
mobilisent les veuves
un cortège s'est ensuite formé fort de
4000 personnes
il a traversé le centre-ville beaucoup
de jeunes quelles que soient leurs
sympathies politiques ont promis de ne
pas oublier d'aller voter le 5 mai pour
jacques chirac
même sans enthousiasme même mobilisation
dont dans beaucoup de métropoles
régionales comme ici à lyon où près de
3000 personnes se sont installées toute
la journée sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville
autant de manifestations spontanées qui
se sont dispersés sans incidents au
moment où démarre à paris un nouveau
rassemblement dans le quartier de la
république quatre à cinq mille personnes
à l'appel du parti communiste de la lcr
ou des verts hier encore diviser la
gauche retrouve sur le pavé un semblant
d'unité en défilant faute de savoir
vraiment où aller politiquement
oui on y retrouvera nos envoyés spéciaux
en direct à la fin de ce journal
les manifestations qui sont en train de
prendre une toute autre ampleur puisque
on signale dix mille personnes en ce
moment à nancy dix mille personnes
également à rouen notamment nombreuses
autres réactions notamment des
associations antiracistes on notera
aussi celle de l'église
le président de la conférence des
évêques de france monseigneur ricard
appel à discerner je cite les vadais les
valeurs fondamentales de la démocratie
sans nommer personne alors on s'arrête
un peu plus longuement sur ce premier
tour sans précédent un peu d'histoire
d'abord on disait le front national
divisé jean-marie le pen en pré-retraite
et bien a finalement réalisé son
meilleur score c'est pour lui le
couronnement de 50 ans de carrière
politique
arnaud bouteille est ce que vous pensez
qu'un jour jean marie le pen conduira la
france en 1972 déjà le patron du tout
nouveau front national
se voit en haut de la fiche quand si on
ne sait jamais les soirs le voulait
pourquoi pas la carrière de jean marie
le pen comme ans sous l'uniforme
direction l'indochine dien bien phu puis
l'algérie dont il refuse d'indépendance
entre les deux voyages jean marie le pen
rencontre pierre poujade et devient à 27
ans le bouillonnant benjamins du palais
bourbon la gouaille le culot jean marie
le pen ne manquent pas puis il trouve
son nouveau thème de prédilection
vis-à-vis d'immigration sauvage en 1983
le front national obtient 17% à dreux
lors des municipales
c'est un premier succès grâce à la
proportionnelle il revient en force à
l'assemblée trois ans plus tard ils sont
alors 35 députés frontistes
jean-marie le pen veut gravir une à une
les marches du pouvoir et se permet
alors toutes les provocations
je ne dis pas que les chambres à gaz
n'ont pas existé mais je crois que c'est
un point de détail de l'histoire de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
le parti communiste lui perd des forces
tandis que l'extrême droite ne cesse
d'en gagner
je veux dire à four crématoire merci aux
aveux en 1997 il joint le geste à la
parole dans les rues de mantes-la-jolie
jean marie le pen agresse une élue
socialiste
il sera condamné en 1998 c'est la crise
la scission le front se déchirent le
parti est au plus bas
la campagne jean marie le pen aura
d'abord compter sur lui même sa verve sa
personnalité même lorsqu'il s'agit de
quémander quelques signatures d'élus
nationale on en récupère une partie puis
on essaye d'en avoir d'autres façon à
combler les trous certains y auront vu
une belle opération de communication
pour la quatrième fois jean-marie le pen
est candidat à la présidentielle d'une
élection à l'autre
il a toujours améliorer son score qui
est voté front national examinons de
plus près la carte de france du vote
jean marie le pen arrive en tête dans
neuf régions sur 22 situé à part la
picardie qu'on ne distingue pas ici si
tu es voilà y compris la picardie sur
cet arc à l'est du pays de l'alsace à la
région paca à noter qu'en 95 seuls ces
deux régions l'avait placé en tête alors
comment expliquer cette poussée est bien
direction l'alsace justement et le petit
village des vies leurs pas de
délinquance
pas de chômage peu d'immigrés mais 45%
hier pour jean marie le pen
reportage christophe medard jean-pierre
pasteur et l'ivi leur petit village
alsacien de 250 âmes pas de délinquance
pas de chômage pas d'immigration
et pourtant cette commune a massivement
voté pour jean marie le pen qui totalise
45 % des suffrages
un vote que personne ici ne veut assumer
on préfère passer son chemin
on peut vous poser une question sur
l'élection présidentielle madame pour
tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté fn ce
mutisme est révélateur je veux dire
peut-être qu'ils ont compris le la
gravité de la situation quoi
les électeurs du front national reste
invisible pourtant on sent bien que le
programme de jean-marie le pen ne laisse
pas insensible nombre de villageois y en
a trop on va dire est envahie de quoi
des étrangers ici eywiller pas prêt pas
précisément ici un aux alentours ou à
dire dans ce village sans histoire la
campagne du front national a porté ses
fruits au delà de l'immigration c'est le
problème de la délinquance qui est mise
en avant
à mon avis c'est un vote contestataire
seydoux lorsqu'il ya quand même de la
sécurité qui s'est produit dans les
petits villages auraient même les
petites petit bourg aux alentours depuis
des dernières présidentielles jean-marie
le pen a gagné 15 % de voix et willer
une progression qui pourrait bien être
confirmé le 5 mai prochain
après l'alsace rurale les grandes villes
des bouches du rhône marseille ou juste
à côté marignane qui a donné 39 % de ses
voix à l'extrême droite fn + mnr par un
des lecteurs recueillis par yannick à
rossi et benoît jours dans un leader de
droite nationale chasse l'autre mais le
vote extrême est bien installée à
marignane ville mégrétistes bruno mégret
12,11 % jean marie le pen 27 70 20 total
qui frise les 40 % parmi des boulistes
toutes les tendances sont représentées
ceux qui parlent le plus volontiers du
vote le pen sont les immigrés italiens
je ferai car ils n'ont pas se contenter
les collègues horse avec or les gens
passent encore été étonnamment on attend
canopée n'est pas sa place et on essaie
de l'électorat marignanais une forte
composante de personnes issues de
l'immigration italienne ou espagnole et
de rapatriés d'afrique du nord à la tête
de la ville depuis 1995 daniel
simonpieri encartés ou mnr ne cache pas
son plaisir devant les résultats
aujourd'hui des gens qui
vent vers ceux qui les écoutent et vers
ce qui leur propose des solutions
même constat à marseille comme en 88 et
95 jean marie le pen est en tête avec 23
points 34% des ventes sanctions et c'est
quand même dommage que ce soit la gauche
ou la droite n'en tiennent pas compte
près de 28% c'est le total des voix de
le pen émigré à marseille 2000 personnes
ont manifesté sur le vieux port parmi
elles ces électeurs qui avait choisi
hier les petits candidats qui ont voté
pour vous en ce nom ont lieu en ce
moment mais bon si j'avais su j'aurais
voté jospin
si les sondages nous avait dit que que
jospin à l'epa passion je pense que
beaucoup de gens aient voté jospin leur
moyen d'expression se limite aujourd'hui
à la manifestation est pour beaucoup au
vote chirac au deuxième qui pourrait
toujours plus de manifestations fera le
point tout à l'heure d'abord nous
retrouverons pascal perrineau bonsoir
vous êtes directeur du cevipof le centre
d'étude de la vie politique française
y at il un électeur type du front
national oui il ya un électeur type et
on retrouve d'ailleurs à cette élection
largement des caractéristiques que l'on
connaissait déjà en 1995
c'est un électorat qui est jeune c'est
un électorat très masculin c'est un
électorat qui fait de très bons scores
en milieu ouvrier et parmi les chômeurs
et puis à les aspects nouveau dans cette
élection
on voit que jean marie le pen a réussi à
sortir de cet électorat traditionnel et
que maintenant ils s'implantent
également dans le milieu rural 18%
paraît-il des agriculteurs ont choisi le
vote en faveur de jean marie le pen et
même il sort d'un certain ghetto
sociologique en faisant des scores qui
ne sont pas négligeables maintenant chez
les cadres moyens et les employés donc
on voit là qu'il ya une véritable
dynamique sociale est ce que cela
signifie que ce n'est plus seulement un
vote protestataire mais que ça peut
devenir aussi un vote conservateur par
exemple n'ont pour l'instant la
dimension protestataires restent
essentiels quand on interroge ses
électeurs on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une
majorité d'électeurs qui nous dit nous
avons voté essentiellement pour
s'opposer aux autres candidats et pas du
tout à cause d'un projet pas du tout à
cause d'un attachement par exemple à la
personnalité de jean-marie le pen on est
véritablement au coeur du vote
protestataire
comme on l'est d'ailleurs avec les
candidats qui ont choisi l'extrême
gauche on a à peu près
le même type de réactions dans les deux
extrêmes autre question qu'on se pose
pascal perrineau celle d'un mouvement
d'ensemble d'une poussée l'ensemble des
partis socialistes des partis populistes
pardon ou d'extrême droite en europe
c'est vrai que le succès de jean marie
le pen en france n'est pas un cas isolé
petit rappel d'abord avec un de
consignes et le parti d'extrême droite
de filip dewinter devient le troisième
parti belge depuis les autres formations
s'entendent pour l'écarter du pouvoir
mais il a encore progressé
aux dernières municipales en autriche en
février 2000 l'extrême droite de jörg
haider s'impose comme la deuxième force
politique et entre au gouvernement en
coalition avec les conservateurs
l'émotion est vive au sein de l'union
européenne qui impose sept mois de
sanctions politiques sans précédent à
l'autriche depuis l'extrême droite est
toujours le gouvernement paie a
fortement reculé aux dernières
municipales en italie en juin 2001 les
alliés de silvio berlusconi prête
serment
parmi eux umberto bossi et la ligue du
nord un parti autonomiste mais qui
développe des thèses proches de
l'extrême droite française notamment sur
l'europe et l'immigration
au danemark le 21 novembre dernier pia
kjaersgaard et son parti d'extrême
droite recueille 12 % des suffrages
elle impose le thème de l'immigration
dans la campagne mais n'entre pas au
gouvernement
le premier de droite depuis 72 ans au
danemark
enfin aux pays bas en mars dernier c'est
au tour de pim fortuyn jusqu alors
plutôt considéré comme une curiosité
politique il rafle 33% des voix aux
municipales de rotterdam
il devient donc le premier parti de la
deuxième ville du pays
homosexuel déclaré ces slogans anti
immigration semble séduire beaucoup de
jeunes les sondages lui prédisent 20
sièges sur 150 aux législatives du 15
mai proche chartis peut-on faire un lien
pascal perrineau y at il des points
communs entre la poussée de tous ces
partis en europe il bien sûr il ya
essentiellement deux liens communs on
s'aperçoit que l'extrême droite prospère
quant au fond on a affaire à des
systèmes politiques quelque peu usé qui
ont du mal à se renouveler dans lequel
les électeurs ne vois pas quelle est
l'alternative c'était le cas par exemple
en août riches
où il y avait une véritable répartition
du pouvoir entre la gauche et la droite
et cela doit nous rappeler vous voyez
quelque chose du cas français l'a poussé
à l'extrême droite vient après cinq ans
de cohabitation entre gauche et droite
où on ne savait plus très bien où est l
opposition et les électeurs qui ont voté
le pen ou eu l'impression que
l'opposition
eh bien c'était jean marie le pen c'est
la première caractéristique et puis il
ya un deuxième facteur qui est un
facteur de fond qu'on retrouve dans
toutes les sociétés européennes c'est
qu'il y a dans toutes les sociétés
aujourd'hui des 15 pays de l'union une
angoisse dans certains milieux vis-à-vis
de ce qu'on pourrait appeler la société
ouverte c'est-à-dire l'ouverture
politique avec la construction accélérée
de l'europe
l'ouverture économique avec la
globalisation l'ouverture culturelle
avec nos sociétés qui deviennent de plus
en plus des sociétés multiculturelles et
l'extrême droite se met dans tous ces
pays à l'avant-garde du pôle qui
condamne cette société ouverte et qui
dit au fond voilà lé notre avenir c'est
de revenir au sein de nos frontières et
de revenir vers une société davantage
clause est refermée sur elle même
merci pascal perrineau en tout cas cette
situation politique française fait la
une des principaux journaux européens
tonalité générale
la france qui aime tant donner des
leçons devraient d'abord se préoccuper
d'elle-même rome londres berlin on
retrouve nos correspondants isabelle
steve bernard lebrun patrice romedenne
pour la presse comme pour la plupart des
italiens
c'est inimaginable qui s'est produit en
france déception
j'avais une bonne opinion des fils le
tremblement de terre le pen est un coup
pour l'europe et une sévère leçon à
méditer estime la presse italienne
la revanche de l'ex parra et le waterloo
de jose pas inquiète le signal d'alarmé
tallien n'a pas payé commente la stampa
pour le journal de centre-droit la
gauche française a désigné berlusconi
comme le danger a exorcisé alors que
c'est chez elles que se trouve la tête
de pont hyper nationaliste et xénophobe
pour le conservateur corriere della
serra beaucoup on s'est demandé si la
formule italienne n'est pas préférable à
la française
et si certaines critiques adressées au
gouvernement italien ne mérite pas
aujourd'hui un sourire ironique vue de
londres
les gros titres sont plutôt sombres
émeutes pour les élections françaises
les photos dit la fiche quotidien du
soir evening standard fait grand cas des
incidents de cette nuit et titre la
victoire de le pen provoque la bataille
de paris
le choc du vote d'extrême droite en
france titre et le très conservateur
times ce matin le vote le pen choc la
france lui répondait en écho le guardian
de gauche côté tabloïd on retiendra le
gros titre du sun le vote de la honte la
france bascule dans le racisme la
réprobation est à la taille de la
surprise considérable et la leçon
politique pourrait aussi valoir en
angleterre par la voix de son porte
parole le premier ministre tony blair se
dit très confiant dans le peuple
français
la presse du soir elle se montre très
inquiète quant aux manifestations à
venir dans les rues de paris
un signal d'alarmé pour toute l'europe
dit la télévision allemande cependant
que la presse écrite s'autorise quelques
noms d'oiseaux ainsi le süddeutsche
zeitung déplore-t-il que lionel jospin
premier ministre le râble été mis hors
course par un soudard d'extrême droite a
toujours dans la presse de gauche
le tagesspiegel estime que jospin n'a
pas su convaincre de ses succès et le
berliner zeitung
raïssa naïveté le pen a fait de lui un
idiot va jusqu'à écrire le quotidien
pour le reste un point fait l'unanimité
l'image de la france est écornée et cela
n'est pas fait pour déplaire à tout le
monde dans un pays où l'extrême droite
la muse personnes on devine que les
mésaventures électorale de la france
sont à deux doigts d'arracher à sourire
à l'homme de la rue qui souvent s'agace
de cette france championne du monde de
la morale universelle exclusivité france
2 patrice romedenne a pu rencontrer tout
à l'heure le chancelier allemand social
démocrate gerhard schröder on écoute des
extrêmes je trouve très regrettable que
l'extrême droite soit devenue si forte
en france je pense que tous les
démocrates en france et en europe ainsi
que les y un cycle parti socialiste vont
faire le nécessaire pour que le pen ne
devienne pas une force significative
je crois que cela est tout à fait
possible les gens qui compense moment en
france vont se rassembler derrière le
président de la république est à noter
aussi cette réaction en autriche
c'est plus qu'une faute de goût estime
le chancelier conservateur paul gang
sous sol qui gouvernent vous ne savez
depuis deux ans avec le parti populiste
jörg haider
nous retrouvons duplex marie france
stirbois à député européen membre du
bureau politique du front national merci
d'être avec nous marie france stirbois
quand on entend des réactions très
négatives sur le front national en
france
vous dites on nous diabolise que
dites-vous toutes ces réactions à
l'étranger en europe mais aux etats unis
aussi
moi je crois que nous ne sommes pas du
tout seul en europe parce qu'il ya des
tas d'européens qui ont voté comme
nouvelle et portugais vous avez les
italiens les norvégiens les hollandais
en fait c'est tout un mouvement de 7 en
marche parce que des gens en ont assez
que les partis politiques ne les écoute
pas et en ont assez entre autres des
problèmes d'insécurité et d'immigration
est ce que pour vous c'est un nouveau
départ pour le fn est ce que
vous allez à nouveau tenter fort de ce
nouveau poids de proposer par exemple
des alliances au rpr ou à d'autres
partis à droite en vue des législatives
écoutez moi je crois qu'on peut déjà
combattre sur nos couleurs on n'a pas
besoin d'alliances
on a besoin que les gens les électeurs
votent pour nous et ce qu'ils ont fait
cette fois-ci qu'ils vont recommencer
la prochaine fois pour le deuxième tour
mais aussi pour les législatives
parce que si nous avons des alliances
aussi bien avec le rpf d'autres nous
risquons de perdre notre âme et nous
risquons surtout de ne pas tenir nos
engagements
alors nous nous avons toujours tenu nos
engagements nous sommes toujours battus
pour des idées pour des convictions et
pas pour des ambitions personnelles
franchement quel est le score que vous
visez pour jean marie le pen au deuxième
tour
écoutez moi je vais tout faire pour
qu'ils se fassent le maximum et qu'il
arrive en premier et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons eu un
formidable élan et surtout les gens sont
outrés de voir tous ces gens qui
descendent dans la rue
ces démocrates ces pseudos démocrates
qui viennent donner des leçons viennent
donner des leçons nous traite de nazis
nous traite de toutes sortes de choses
alors qu'il y a des milliers de gens au
front national qui ont combattu pendant
la guerre
nous avons eu nos députés européens il
était compagnon de la libération est ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui en train de nous
montrer du doigt qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont peut-être collaboré comme
les communistes qui pendant une année on
va jouer le pacte germano-soviétique
bien où des étudiants pour le pl a suffi
aux non non j'ai vu aussi des gens d'un
autre âge quant aux lycéens et aux
étudiants dès qu'ils apprennent je crois
l'histoire et ils verront que pendant
l'histoire est trop de l'histoire
d'algérie histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale il ya des tas de gens de droite
qui se sont battus contre le nazisme
merci marie france stirbois d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et puis nous
avons voulu savoir aussi comment on
réagit ce dans les pays d'émigration
vers la france
l'afrique noire par exemple à abidjan
côte d'ivoire
eric monier bruno girodon abidjan on
appelle ce lieu la sorbonne chaque jour
on y commentent l'actualité aujourd'hui
le premier tour de l'élection française
et le score de jean marie le pen
entre surprise et colère verte
un collégien bientôt à la traduction
c'est pas normal que le perso de la
culture de la civilisation occidentale
plus tomber si bas dites leur que nous
sommes choqués en afrique est
profondément choquée j'ai pas de
multiples années parce que je
m'attendais à tout sauf trouver les
peines pour second tour s'ils les pelles
pas mal je le dis a eu au pouvoir et
campsas ne vois rien qui vivent à face
et nous trouverons aussi une solution
offensive qui vivent ici c'est la grande
phrase qui accusent la sarthe les droits
de l'homme en 48 je suis aujourd'hui
la france salue l'avènement du nous on a
fait la queue copier après l'élection
présidentielle américaine et l'ubuesque
décompte des voix
voilà pour les africains avec les
résultats d'hier en france une nouvelle
preuve de l'imperfection des démocraties
occidentales souvent pourtant imposé en
modèle dans cette partie du monde
la nation prompte à s'ériger en donneuse
de leçon est tombé du haut de son
piédestal écrit de son côté le quotidien
sénégalais le soleil
et puis réaction aussi en israël où on
trouve charles enderlin qu'on a aperçu
il ya un instant charles
le ministre de l'intérieur israélien eli
yishai exhorte ce soir les juifs de
france à faire leurs valises
oui tout à fait eli yishaï et vice
premier ministre et ministre de
l'intérieur il est le chef du parti
shass qui la troisième formation
politique du pays avec 17 députés au
parlement la knesset chasse est un
mouvement ultra-orthodoxe sépharade
c'est-à-dire qui regroupent
essentiellement des ultra orthodoxes
venus d'afrique du nord des pays arabes
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'une
personnalité gouvernemental israélien
lance un tel appel aux juifs de france
déjà monsieur sharon leur avait
conseillé de venir s'installer en israël
jusqu'à présent ces appels ne sont pas
vraiment entendu l'année dernière 1002
personnes ont choisi de quitter la
france pour venir s'installer en israël
on sera dans quelques mois si ce chiffre
est en hausse mais d'un mot charles est
ce que c'est significatif d'une
inquiétude assez profonde en israël au
lendemain de ses résultats en france
la presse israélienne a effectivement
parlé d'une grande inquiétude est
présenté l'élection comme un tremblement
de terre comme en europe
merci charles on revient en france
maintenant et à la campagne pour le
second tour avec cette question qui ne
semble toujours pas tranché jacques
chirac
va-t-il débattre avec jean marie le pen
comme celle usages entre les deux
qualifiés pour le second tour
on a entendu des versions
contradictoires depuis hier aux
dernières nouvelles ce serait oui
alix bouilhaguet maya l us ni date de
naissance 1974
qu'on l'appelle duel débats vont encore
face à face depuis près de trente ans
entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle les deux candidats
s'affrontent et des expressions reste
pouvez-vous vraiment contester ma
version des choses en me regardant dans
les yeux dans les yeux c'est la conteste
des répliques parfois décisive vous
n'avez pas le monopole du coeur il parle
des phrases qui ont disent long
c'est quand même ennuyeux que dans
l'intervalle vous soyez devenus vos
l'homme du passif alors aujourd'hui il y
aura t'il débat entre jacques chirac et
jean marie le pen ce matin la question
semblait réglé c'est une tradition du
week-end et je vois pourquoi ce débat
n'aurait pas lieu au même moment
pourtant une autre version celle de
roselyne bachelot la porte parole du
candidat chirac
j'imagine que jacques chirac ne souhaite
pas ce débat déclaré sur rtl
il jugera dans les prochaines heures ce
qu'il va faire s'il finit par avoir lieu
ce face à face promet d'être musclé les
deux hommes se détestent depuis
longtemps
chirac à une analyse dès le départ dès
le début des années 80 il dit le pen
c'est une invention de médian il en veut
évidemment énormément à mitterrand mais
je crois que peu à peu il a point
détesté de plus en plus le pen est l'un
des grands drames de chirac c'est que il
perd toutes les élections il percute une
série d'élections à cause de le pen
c'est le pen qu'il fait perdre au fond
pendant toute la campagne jean marie le
pen n'a eu qu'un seul adversaire jacques
chirac se sont ils rencontrés entre les
deux tours de la présidentielle de 1988
comme l'affirment le président du front
national
un débat pourrait apporter des réponses
si une rencontre avait lieu cette fois
ci elle se déroulerait devant les
français bonsoir michèle alliot-marie
vous êtes présidente du rpr je sais ce
que vous allez me dire c'est jacques
chirac qui décidera mais vous est-ce que
vous pensez que ce débat doit avoir lieu
vous personnellement c'est un vrai débat
oui puisque cela contribue à éclairer
les français la condition que ce soit un
vrai débat et monsieur le pen nous a
plus habitué aux invectives et aux
injures que véritablement au débat sur
les idées pour vous jean marie le pen
c'est un candidat un adversaire du
deuxième tour comme un autre c'est un
adversaire de longue date
c'est un adversaire qui la dernière fois
a mis en place monsieur jospin puisque
c'est par ces candidats qui l'a maintenu
en triangulaire au deuxième tour qu'il a
permis à la majorité socialiste se
constituer mais michèle alliot-marie
j'allais dire pour vous est ce qu'il ya
un climat particulier ce qu'il y à un
contexte particulier pour ce second tour
où vous dites non pour nous c'est une
joute électorale finalement comme une
autre pour ce second tour je dis que ce
qui est en jeu ce sont des valeurs qui
sont d'abord les valeurs de la
république et pour nous c'est quelque
chose d'important pour nous gaullistes
les valeurs de la république les valeurs
humanistes
c'est essentiel et c'est effectivement
l'enjeu du débat de ce deuxième tour
et puis bien entendu pour ce deuxième
tour ce sont également les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres pour permettre le
développement de la france c'est le
projet de jacques chirac pour la france
et les français
un projet qui est destinée à mieux
répondre
aux attentes aux angoisses aux espoirs
également des français qui n'ont pas été
pris en compte par les socialistes au
cours des dernières années
mais michèle alliot marie si vous deviez
porter une appréciation sur ce qui s'est
passé hier soir vous diriez finalement
c'est une bonne chose pour nous jacques
chirac est en tête il semble à peu près
assurée de l'emporter pour le deuxième
tour où vous diriez il se passe quelque
chose de grave en france parce que jean
marie le pen est au second tour j'étais
d'abord une chose c'est que les français
décident
il faut respecter le choix des électeurs
ceci dit il est vrai que d'avoir un
candidat d'extrême droite au deuxième
tour fait un événement considérable et
qui appelle de notre part une réaction
forte une mobilisation forte
un rassemblement autour des valeurs qui
sont les nôtres les valeurs de la
république les valeurs de l'homme mais
également les valeurs d'une france
moderne que nous souhaitons
finalement ce qui s'est passé hier soir
aussi c'est la sanction de cinq années
d'inaction des socialismes sur des
sujets qui intéressent très directement
les français dont ils m'ont parlé au
cours de tous mes déplacements en
province de ces dernières semaines c'est
à dire le problème des retraites c'est à
dire le problème de l'insécurité
c'est à dire le problème du poids
excessif de l'administration j'entendais
tout à l'heure le responsable monsieur
et renault qui parlait des agriculteurs
moi ce que j'ai entendu c'est la
réaction des agriculteurs qu'ils disent
mais pour nous donner éventuellement une
petite subvention il faut remplir cette
papiers différents et si une profonde
une virgule n'y avons pas droit
ils me disent les 35 heures et est ce
que les 35 heures cela veut dire que
nous allons devoir dire pardonnez moi
c'est presque caricatural mais tellement
vrai devoir dire à nos vaches arrêter de
faire du lait parce que notre ouvrier a
fini ses 35 heures
ce sont toutes ces aberrations qui ont
été très durement ressentie par les
français parce qu'ils ont l'impression
d'avoir été méprisé de ne pas avoir été
écouté et je crois qu'ils les ont aussi
exprimé de cette façon mais recèle merci
michèle alliot marie d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
on rappelle que jean saint-josse et
corinne lepage ont appelé à voter pour
jacques chirac
christine boutin annoncera sa décision
mercredi rappelons leur score 4,23 pour
jean saint-josse 1,10 9% pour christine
boutin
1,88 pour corinne lepage là encore des
chiffres quasi définitifs
autre chiffre et il explique peut-être
le bon score de l'extrême droite
et ils sont en tout cas sans précédent
se de l'abstention 28 4% à la décimale
près nous vous donnions d'ailleurs dès
hier soir 19h on l'a beaucoup dit c'est
un record
alors comment les abstentionnistes
d'hier ont ils accueilli aujourd'hui ce
résultat en portage près de montpellier
karine comazzi parce qu'elles pensent
ils hier encore l'abstentionniste
s'ébroue et insouciants sur la plage de
palavas
aujourd'hui l'ambiance comme la mer il y
est plus agitée s'abstenir c'est laisser
la l'apparat n'importe quoi culpabiliser
non mais je vais me risquer à billy's
c'est à dire voter au deuxième tour
alanguie contre les rochers chacune
explique le sens de son vote sanction de
la veille j'ai préféré m'abstenir parce
que j'étais mécontent
parce que j fox il faut qu'il se passe
quelque chose si je pense que c'est un
électrochoc et que ça va peut-être
réveiller les gens sur la responsabilité
du vote quand on fait tout simplement
inconscience et mauvaise coïncidence ont
desservi ce premier tour carrière
c'était l'ouverture de la pêche aux
carnassiers et au bord de l'hérault les
lecteurs pêcheurs avaient déjà tranché
le suspense est plus intéressant on va
plutôt dire à la pêche premier tour les
élections ça sera pareil qu'il se soit
ça surprendre qui que ce soit l'autre
hasard du calendrier ce sont les
vacanciers parisiens qui en ont fait les
frais je trouve ça scandaleux qu'ils
aient prévu ça pendant les vacances
scolaires de paris où les vacances
scolaires d'une autre zone mais ça s'est
trouvé que ce soit les vacances
scolaires je comprends devrait pas il
aurait pu penser ça nos amis les
énarques saint guilhem le désert un
dimanche d'élections les lecteurs
touristes se disperse entre les oliviers
rêvant d'une campagne
enfin à la hauteur de ses attentes et on
revient maintenant sur la défaite
cuisante de la gauche plurielle en
général et lionel jospin en particulier
la carte de france nouveau jaws pain
elle est très vite vu une seule région
midi pyrénées la placer en tête avec
moins de 20% des voix alors que s'est il
passé y at il eu vote sanction reportage
d'abord auprès d'une clientèle disons
traditionnels de la gauche
les employés à bayonne ils étaient 350 à
travailler dans l'entreprise ruelle
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
composants électroniques 350 personnes
licenciées suite à la liquidation
judiciaire de la société
tous se disent se disent déçus de la
politique
reportage caroline femme flic du mail
voter rubel pas une consigne de vote
mais l'expression d'un rejet des
politiques menées par la gauche comme
par la droite
les 350 anciens salariés de cette
entreprise ont reçu leur lettre de
licenciement en fin de semaine tenté par
l'abstention certains ont malgré tout
regret d'autres ont clairement décidé de
ne pas donner l'heure
je sais pas vous mais moi y ait des gens
de ma famille de ses amis et ses acquis
quand on a parlé des votes
présidentielle ils ont tous été
influencé par ce qui m'arrive à moi ou
et keith a influé sur les discours
politiques on a reçu il n'y a pas
d'action derrière ce ne sont que des
promesses
et quand on fait que des promesses à la
fin mais on n'y croit plus et on se
venge
c'est ce qui s'est passé hier mais si
certains se sont abstenus hier pourtant
ils ont été surpris des résultats comme
partout d'un séisme politique dans un
contexte de catastrophe sociale certes
beaucoup sont déçus de la politique mais
le second tour ne les laisse pas
indifférent déjà qu'on a peur parce que
envie d'une situation dramatique
alors imaginez vous la médecine obtenir
mais je pense qu'au second de touche
pour les fruits car il ya quand même
quelque chose en jeu donc je pense que
je vais forcément dont l'avenir est
incertain pour ces anciens salariés
entre les deux tours et à quelques
semaines des législatives
il tâte encore un sursaut des élus autre
explication peut-être la mauvaise
campagne de lionel jospin positionnement
flottant déclarations malheureuses
retour sur ces quelques semaines qui ont
fait plonger la gauche alexandre kara
l'inventaire a déjà commencé les bureaux
sont vides
dans quelques jours il ne restera plus
trace de l'atelier de campagne de lionel
jospin à peine des souvenirs celui des
sanglots d'un soir alors que le parti
socialiste s'effondre son candidat se
retire de la vie politique
j'assume pleinement la responsabilité de
cet échec et j'en tire les conclusions
en me retirant de la vie politique après
après la fin de l'élection
présidentielle pourtant lionel jospin
avait commencé la campagne confiant mais
très vite on a du mal à situer la
couleur exacte du candidat je suis
socialiste d'inspiration mais le projet
que je propose au pays ce pas un projet
socialiste venu bien tard le virage à
gauche ne convainc personne
d'autant que la campagne a du mal à
prendre millenia fin pour recommencer
comme avant la politique à pied les
réunions de campagne à pied dans les
villages sur les communes dans les
cantons la médiatisation ça tue le rêve
et c'est vrai la mobilisation est faible
la campagne de lionel jospin jugé par
beaucoup trop technocratique du mal à
déchaîner les passions
si on ajoute que les sondages annoncent
comme une évidence et de finaliste pour
beaucoup de militants
le premier tour apparaît comme une
simple formalité et la communication
n'arrange rien nous n'avons pas su
communiquer moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
comme j'ai l'impression qu'il y à une
france d'en bas qui rejette la france
d'en haut des erreurs comme le dérapage
sur l'âge du président devant la presse
son retour de l'île de la réunion
mais surtout une communication
l'américaine orchestrée par des
publicitaires pas assez naturel trop
d'artifices une dictature permanente des
sondages finissent par brouiller l'image
ci au parti socialiste on parle d'échec
collectif c'est d'abord celui d'un homme
qui aujourd'hui a décidé de tirer un
trait sur sa vie politique
enfin dernier élément avant de retrouver
françois hollande éléments avancés
d'ailleurs par lionel jospin lui même la
dispersion des voix à gauche
avec la multiplication des candidatures
c'est l'occasion de rappeler les scores
là encore ils sont définitifs ou presque
jean pierre chevènement 5 33% des voix
doit elle ma mère 5,25 pour cent à
christiane taubira 2,30 2% des voix que
répond-il à ces accusations entre
guillemets et milan sont éric messi
au lendemain du premier tour christiane
taubira a retrouvé son vélo et une vie
normale comme toute la gauche elle s'est
réveillée groggy mais la candidate
radicale ne se sont coupables en rien
même si un quart de ses voix aurait
suffi à qualifier lionel jospin pour le
second tour serait traité les électeurs
de façon bien ces vols bien mais
présentait bien et responsable
j'ai fait une campagne plaire sur des
positionnements sans ambiguïté avec un
programme précis je crois que c'est sur
ça que les électeurs se sont prononcés à
la ligue communiste révolutionnaire
le verdict est plus sévère crédité de
0,5 pour cent d'intentions de vote en
début de campagne
olivier besancenot a créé la surprise
avec ses 4 % mais le jeune candidat
fekter la firme
tu vois il ne les a pas volés aux
socialistes c'est pas la multiplication
des candidatures à gauche qui est
responsable de tout ça c'est
malheureusement des raisons politiques
si jospin a baissé c'est simplement il
peut s'en prendre qu'à sa propre
campagne
il a commencé à une campagne de centre
gauche ou personnes voyaient la
différence entre chirac et jospin elle
essaie de se rattraper la dernière
minute en sortant des mesurettes qui
satisfaisait personnes la présidentielle
2002 et historique pour les truffes qui
pour la première fois sous la vème
république
les trois formations d'extrême gauche à
peine plus de 10% des voix autre
difficulté pour les socialistes la
gauche plurielle ajoutées les unes aux
autres les voix des verts du mouvement
des citoyens et du parti communiste
aurait permis aux candidats socialistes
d'atteindre plus de 32% des voix
voilà c'est un élément parmi d'autres
françois hollande merci d'être avec nous
comment vous sentez-vous aujourd'hui
pardonnez moi l'expression est ce qu'il
ya une gueule de bois ou est-ce que vous
êtes déjà en train de projeter dans
l'avenir
non il ya comme vous dites une gueule de
bois elle est naturelle parce que nous
n'imaginions pas et je pense les
français non plus être dans cette
situation d'avoir deux candidats de
droite et l'autre de l'extrême droite au
second tour de l'élection présentielle
c'est-à-dire de l'élection majeure
alors nous emportons sans doute la
responsabilité je remarque d'ailleurs
que lionel jospin est un homme digne
honnête il a lui même annoncé
qui se retirait de la vie politique et
pas beaucoup de leaders en france qui
après avoir perdu des élections
annoncent leur départ de la vie
politique je pense que ça peut servir de
leçon à d'autres mais c'est vrai que
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la fois dans
la tristesse mais en même temps c'est
normal dans la détermination dans le
combat déjà un mot un peu personnel
françois hollande mais avoue à 19 heures
quand vous apprenez ou peut-être un peu
avant 19 heures
quels sont les résultats des sondages
des estimations qui seront données au
public à 20h et que vous voyez jean
marie le pen et devant lionel jospin
qu'est ce que vous ressentez je ressens
au delà de la surprise assez terrifiante
une immense tristesse tristesse pour
lionel jospin ce qu'il a fait pour le
pays on peut critiquer son action mais
convenons que nous avons là affaire un
homme d'état un homme honnête un homme
sérieux même si on peut j'entendais des
commentaires sur sa campagne évoqué un
certain nombre de difficultés
nous avons aussi exprimé une immense
tristesse pour pour notre pays parce que
c'est quand même pas digne de la france
que d'avoir un candidat de l'extrême
droite au second tour de l'élection et
puis au delà de l'émotion delà de la
peine au delà de la solidarité pour
notre candidat nous sommes tous dit
qu'on pouvait pas en rester là qu'on
pouvait pas baisser les bras
que les français n'avaient pas voulu ça
même si on devait respecter leur vote et
qu'il fallait en leur nom au nom de tout
ce que nous avons fait depuis des années
au nom de ce que nous portons les idéaux
de la gauche au nom de ce que nous avons
à préparer les élections législatives
c'est en sorte d'être à la hauteur des
combats qui viennent alors vous avez
appelé officiellement le ps a appelé
officiellement à voter pour jacques
chirac au second tour aujourd'hui quelle
sera l'attitude des militants
socialistes vont ils suivre cette
invitation dans le fief de lionel jospin
à toulouse
reportage isabelle de lyon david bres
ces deux jeunes viennent pour adhérer le
parti socialiste a un succès fou
depuis ce matin à toulouse où je vis
depuis depuis longtemps mais c'est vrai
que là ouais j'ai envie de le monde
pourquoi spécialement aujourd'hui parce
que la claque d'hier fait qu'il faut se
bouger leur premier acte militant et de
s'engager
le second sera voté chirac selon la
jeune socialiste qui les reçoit n'a pas
le choix je crois que le plus important
c'est de se faire barrage au front
national chiao de mou trop abattu pour
réagir les socialistes qui nous en l'air
soir quand lionel jospin annonce qu'il
se retire de la vie politique
certains ténors du parti ont déjà
déclaré qu'il faudrait voter chirac
mais ici on n'arrive pas à le dire
l'élection de chirac est acquise
aujourd'hui tout le monde le sait n'est
pas envie de pour vous de voter pour
prendre en cours pour l'heure chirac
mais nous allons en décidés à bloquer
viennent
le choc est tellement rude ce soir il
faut d'abord voir s'ils voulaient soi
même
ils ont 13 jours pour se faire à cette
idée voter pour quelqu'un qu'ils ont
toujours combattu
bon maintenant je sais pas si j'y vois
si j'ai redonné ma chérie rauque et mes
plats tout sauf le pen c'est bien sûr
bien sûr mais c'est vrai que la réaction
tous les socialistes c'est le choix
entre un avant un fasciste est un voleur
et monteur quoi donc c'est difficile
c'est vrai que c'est difficile dans le
bureau du secrétaire fédéral trône le
portrait de lionel jospin élevé soudain
au rang d' autorité morale
ici le prochain objectif c'est les
législatives les législatives où vous
serez au vous porterez le flambeau donc
françois hollande pour le ps
au delà il y a besoin évidemment d'un
nouveau leader alors qui sera t'il est
ce que ce sera laurent fabius dominique
strauss kahn martine aubry ou vous même
peut-être ce sera nous tous je pense que
dans cette campagne on doit avoir un
objectif
nous ne serons pas au second tour de
l'élection partielle il faut faire
barrage à l'extrême droite écarté ce
péril la et faire en sorte que nous
ayons un président qui soit dans le
cercle de la démocratie même si jacques
chirac restera notre adversaire parce
qu'il incarne la politique de la droite
il voudra aux élections légistatives
faire une confirmation d'un scrutin qui
a été un scrutin manqué qui a créé une
immense frustration et donc c
la gauche d'abord au parti socialiste
dans toute sa diversité avec toutes ces
équipes et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
personnalités éminentes de mener
campagne de mener l'action avec un
programme qui reprendra l'essentiel de
nos réflexions en ajoutera d'autres
parce que nous avons entendu le message
des français sur les services publics
sur la lutte contre les violences sur
l'éducation sur les retraites ce sera un
virage à droite
c'est une fuite en avant il s'agit de
faire un virage par rapport à ce que les
français nous ont dit ça je suis au mans
pas un virage de ce côté là il s'agit de
prendre en compte le résultat de premier
tour on aurait souhaité qu'il soit
différent on aurait préféré qu'il n'y
ait pas de dispersion qui n'est pas
d'abstention
nous aurions à ce pont là lionel jospin
au second tour de l'élection serait
quand même une autre allure et lionel
jospin ce serait même en situation de
pouvoir l'emporter sur jacques chirac
ce n'est pas le cas puisque nous
n'aurons pas ce grand débat au moment de
l'élection présidentielle il faut qu'on
l'est au moment des élections
législatives et c'est notre
responsabilité en tout cas la mienne de
faire en sorte que les socialistes
arrivent en bonne heure avec un
programme de combat avec un programme
juste pour le pays
un programme qui sera celui de la
mobilisation de toutes les énergies pour
que nous puissions l'emporter pour les
élections les gésiers et nous le ferons
avec la gauche unie oui parce qu'il ne
peut pas être question d'arriver dans la
même situation que dimanche soir avec
une gauche dispersée avec une gauche
éclatée qui n'est pas en situation de
faire entendre sa voix mais oui mais
françois hollande vous vous êtes
candidat j'allais dire à moyen terme à
reprendre les rênes de la gauche
socialiste
moi ma responsabilité comme premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste c'est de
mettre tous les socialistes dans le
mouvement aujourd'hui nous avons à faire
ce choix pour la présidentielle mais
nous avons surtout à préparer les
élections légistatives ma tâche
aujourd'hui moi je suis là pour relever
le flambeau pour ramener l'ensemble des
socialistes vers la fierté vers
l'honneur qui doit être le leur et vous
n'est ce pas candidat à faire plus
écoutez si l'ensemble la gauche avec les
socialistes nous sommes en capacité
comme je le crois de l'emporter aux
élections législatives nous verrons la
place de chacun mais en tout cas moi je
couperai pleinement la mienne au nom des
socialistes ce que demandent nos
électeurs nous avons aujourd'hui des
milliers
demande d'adhésion au parti socialiste
j'aurais préféré ce soit dans un autre
contexte un contexte de victoire
aujourd'hui à plein de jeunes il ya
plein d'électeurs peut-être même qu'ils
n'ont pas voté pour nous et ont pu voter
pour d'autres candidats qui eux mêmes se
sont abstenus qui vont venir travailler
avec vont venir travailler derrière le
parti suisse derrière la gauche à
condition qu'elle soit unie et soit
c'est ma responsabilité d'emmener tout
le monde vers le combat des ligier des
intrants des mots principal un tout
dernier mot françois hollande vous avez
parlé j'imagine avec lionel jospin
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est totalement
abattu démoralisé ou au contraire à ce
qui s'est fait une raison
menad jospin il a été digne du début
jusqu'à la fin
digne dans cette fonction de premier
ministre qu'il assumera jusqu'au bout
digne dans sa tâche de candidat digne
dans son départ lui quand il a pris
conscience de l'échec
il n'a pas cherché en pointer la
responsabilité sur d'autres il assumer
lui même il a dit c'est l'échec c'est le
mien même si ça pouvait être le nôtre et
je pars je trouve qu'il ya tant d'hommes
politiques qui n'ont pas ce réflexe que
je veux ici saluer la qualité de du
comportement et l'attitude de la neige
on vous sent un peu ému mais comment
l'avez-vous trouvé aujourd'hui
ragaillardis déprimé je les trouvais à
son poste de travail
il finira sa tâche avec responsabilité
je les trouvais dans une certaine mesure
maintenant sur une autre partie de sa
vie une autre partie de sa vie va va
s'ouvrir
on fait pas de la politique avi on fait
pas la politique jusqu'au bout je ne
peins ce n'est pas comme d'autres
vous en connaissez qui n'arrête jamais
parce que c'est pas simplement pour les
autres c'est d'abord pour eux même les
neiges jospin c'était pour les autres
merci françois hollande d'avoir répondu
à nos questions poursuit la revue de
détail
à gauche avec
les réactions dans le camp de jean
pierre chevènement et notamment celle
assez attendu du juge eric halphen le
juge qui avait voulu entendre jacques
chirac et qui aujourd'hui annonce qu'il
va voter pour lui écouter ces têtes hier
soir ça va être le choix entre charybde
et scylla
je préfère encore voter car yves de
saint jacques chirac c'est un scoop je
vais voter jacques chirac est donc un
sursaut vital et j'appelle persuadé que
la belle personne moi je voterai jacques
chirac je suis pas en mesure d'en
appeler aux landaises sur son république
pense que ce serait pire pour tous pour
tous les français que l'extrême droite
arrive voilà et puis un mot aussi de
l'extrême gauche arlette laguiller on va
d'abord rappelé les scores de l'extrême
gauche score sans précédent puisque on
est près de 11% des voix si l'on
additionne les cinq points 72 % d'arette
laguiller les 4,25 d'olivier besancenot
et les 0,47 de daniel gluckstein là
encore chiffres quasi définitifs
arlette laguiller qui a donné un
communiqué sur son attitude au deuxième
tour je n'appelle pas à l'abstention
dit-elle j'appelle l'ensemble des
travailleurs ayant en particulier ceux
qui ont voté le pen à ne pas voter pour
lui
mais elle n'appelle pas non plus à voter
pour jacques chirac
autrement dit chacun en tirera les
conclusions qu'il souhaite
autre enseignement du scrutin
l'effondrement du parti communiste
français robert hue et distancer
précisément par arlette laguiller mais
aussi par olivier besancenot 3,37 pour
105 points de moins qu'il ya sept ans et
la survie même du parti qui est en cause
et les nuques maxime soûlard face à la
configuration de ce second tour le parti
communiste français appelle à utiliser
le bulletin de vote jacques chirac pour
faire en sorte que le candidat le pen
soit le plus bas possible
je crois que
c'est comme ça que les choses doivent
être posées aujourd'hui moins d'un
million d'électeurs se sont portés hier
sur le candidat robert hue une
catastrophe un grave échec selon les
propres mots des dirigeants du pc jamais
depuis sa création le parti communiste
n'était descendu aussi bas à la
libération le pcf rassemble cinq fois
plus de voix il est alors le premier
parti de france
des ministres communistes entre au
gouvernement les avec leur départ en
1947 commence une longue période
d'opposition alliée indéfectible de
moscou dépourvue d'esprit critique sur
le stalinisme le parti communiste se
marginalise en 1958 avec le retour du
général de gaulle il n'obtient que dix
députés à l'assemblée en 1966 waldeck
rochet succède à maurice torres à la
tête du parti un accord électoral et
signer avec les socialistes
l' influence du pc remonte elle
culminera une dernière fois en 1969
jacques duclos son candidat à l'élection
présidentielle obtient plus de 21% des
suffrages
1972 le parti communiste signe un
programme commun de gouvernement avec le
parti socialiste en 76 lors de son 22ème
congrès il renonce à la dictature du
prolétariat mais ni cette stratégie
d'union de la gauche ni cette amorce de
mutation ne lui profite aux cantonales
de 1976 pour la première fois le parti
communiste est devancé par le parti
socialiste
le déclin est alors inexorable 15% des
voix à la présidentielle de 80 pour
georges marchais -2 7% pour andré
lajoinie en 88 8 et demi pour 195 pour
robert hue trois et demi aujourd'hui ses
frais de campagne ne seront même pas
remboursé la crise du parti communiste
est à la fois politique et financière
alors que s'est-il passé dans les
bastions traditionnels du pc reportage à
vénissieux dans le rhône
le parti communiste qui a perdu en sept
ans la moitié de ses voix au profit du
front national sur place benoit gadret
jean-claude marque qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on peut basculer d'un vote à gauche
avant le paiement
la déception la déception est il battait
pour la plupart à gauche
il va désormais pour jean marie le pen
vénissieux n'est plus le bastion
communiste des années 70 de 40 % le
parti est passé à 8 hier le front
national en a profité en partie aux
minguettes mais surtout dans les vieux
quartiers résidentiels
pour ces deux sympathisants et
l'explication tient avant tout à
l'insécurité au sentiment d'abandon
j'ai donné beaucoup de travail dans le
quartier jallet discuter avec les gens
et c'est le premier point qui était pris
en compte quoi et ils vous reprocherai
ne pas faire assez quoi autre
explication l'image plus
institutionnelle du parti communiste
depuis qu'il participe au gouvernement
on n'est plus dans la contestation n'est
plus dans le nez plus dans combat c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'on n'est plus
dans le combat et c'est pour ça que les
partis comme arlette laguiller olivier
besancenot ont pu retirer de certaines
populations qui avant étaient en pc
andré gerin et le maire communiste son
discours ferme sur la sécurité a fait de
lui un dissident dans le parti a je
pense qu'on s'est coupé des réalités
populaires notre peuple tout ce qui a
fait 10 d'entités l'originalité du parti
gaulliste français
aujourd'hui est passé à perte et profit
parce qu'il estime que les scrutins lui
a donné raison
andré gerin demande aujourd'hui la
démission des dirigeants du parti avant
de revenir aux manifestations
d'hostilité au front national la
question sur les sondages ça devient une
habitude après chaque élection mais il
est vrai que personne n'avait prévu la
présence de jean-marie le pen au second
tour
vincent fourcade daniel levy la sphère
semblait pourtant réglé depuis plusieurs
semaines un premier tour avec 14
figurants et deux champions consacrés
dont on évalue et déjà les chansons
second tour à votre avis qui l'emportera
lors de la prochaine élection
présidentielle jacques chirac ou de
neige aux pas un tour de scrutin plus
tard et la fiction tant relaté vole en
éclats les instituts de sondages n'ont
rien vu venir des sondeurs dont les
méthodes d'enquêté d' analyse des
réponses fournies sont aujourd'hui
sévèrement critiqué ils ont des
corrections ce qu'ils appellent même des
redressements dans leur jargon ils ne le
disent pas trop à l'extérieur ils disent
la cuisine ça repose sur une sorte de
vision de la réalité politique sur des
suppositions
on avait par exemple un sondeur qui nous
disait à la veille du scrutin que
désormais sans doute on surévalue est
plutôt le front national on voit ce
qu'il en est aujourd'hui
jean marie le pen qui touche son d'âge
confondues n'avait jamais été crédité de
plus de 14% des voix
nous sommes bien loin du score atteint
hier soir pour les sondeurs un seul
coupable le sondé qui rechigneraient à
vous et sa sympathie pour le président
du front national
il est vrai que depuis très longtemps
nous sous-estiment néanmoins le pen
sous-estimé nous le x 2 donc il faut
bien penser que dans la france
d'aujourd'hui
la quantité de gens qui votent le pen
considère néanmoins que de le dire est
un aveu qu'il souhaite pas faire et
amusant et ce n'est pas la seule erreur
commise
les sondeurs également prise en défaut
sur le score du premier ministre deux
points de moins que prévu et sur celui
de robert hue
car avec 3,6 pour cent des suffrages le
candidat communiste à fédérer quasiment
deux fois moins d'électeurs que ce que
les sondages lui promettait
retour maintenant à skis et l'autre
actualité du jour l'autre conséquence
l'autre est fait de ce premier tour les
manifestations ont parlé en début de
journal de trente mille personnes dans
une vingtaine de villes de france ce
chiffre est très largement dépassé
puisque on signale en ce moment douze
mille personnes à tour dix mille à rouen
un an si 5000 personnes au moins à dijon
plusieurs milliers de personnes à
marseille trois mille manifestants à
saint-etienne
et puis ils sont aussi plusieurs
milliers à paris ils se déplacent mario
nous retrouvons jeff vite imbert il
était à république a sur la place de la
nation
place de la bastille où êtes-vous jeff
et que se passe-t-il très exactement je
suis effectivement place de la bastille
comme vous pouvez le constater
dernièrement la manifestation assez
consistants disloquer la circulation a
été rétablie 6 place de la bastille et
tout à l'heure vous allez peut-être le
voir sur ces images il était donc
quelques 10000 sur cette place très
symbolique de la bastille il venait vous
l'avez dit de la place de la république
si vous connaissez paris 7 environ
un kilomètre et demi visite est
actuellement ils seraient entre quatre
et cinq mille à être réunis place de la
nation c'est également à un ou deux
kilomètres de cette place de la bastille
alors dans cette manifestation comme
depuis hier soir on entend toujours les
mêmes slogans anti front national anti
le pen beaucoup de gens qui disent je
les cite leur honte d'être français est
en tête des cortèges on retrouve des
leaders de partis politiques en
particulier ceux de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire d'olivier besancenot est
également les leaders des verts voilà
jeff c'est la question que j'allais vous
poser on a parlé de manifestations
spontanées
on a aussi parlé effectivement de
nombreuses associations ou de quelques
partis politiques qui appellent à
manifester ce que ces manifestations
sont organisées ou est-ce qu'elles sont
effectivement spontanée mais il ya un
peu des deux c'est à dire qu'il ya une
sorte de réaction spontanée notamment
des jeunes des lycéens qui depuis hier
soir
des files spontanément dans les rues de
la plupart des villes de france et puis
il ya des partis politiques avec en
point de ce que je vous citais donc la
lcr et les verts qui veulent commencer à
faire en quelque sorte monter la
pression avant vous savez la grande
manifestation qui est prévue le 1er mai
le jour même où jean marie le pen lui
compte réunir ses partisans autour de la
célébration de jeanne d'arc
merci 'j'ai fait dix ans que ce soit
sans faire de calculs précis on est au
moins à 50 ou 60 mille personnes dans
les rues de france manifestation donc
d'hostilité au front national
après l'annnonce de la présence de
jean-marie le pen au second tour
rapidement on va passer en revue le
reste de l'actualité avec d'abord la
proposition faite aux douaniers par
laurent fabius 2
nouvelle revalorisation de leur prime de
risque proposition doublée par rapport à
celle qui avait été fait
au départ ça soit une enveloppe de 10
millions d'euros environ mais ces
mesures devrait prendre effet au 1er
juillet la tendance ready temps à la
reprise du travail à madrid un attentat
à la voiture piégée devant le siège de
la compagnie pétrolière repsol y tf les
enquêteurs orientent leur enquête vers
le thé à la pâte victimes mais
d'importants dégâts matériels il s'agit
du troisième attentat à la voiture
piégée depuis le début de l'année un
bilan
la réouverture de la tour pirelli le
gratte-ciel le plus haut d'italie il
était fermé depuis jeudi après avoir été
heurtée vous le savez par un avion de
tourisme
le crash avait fait trois morts et 29
blessés les autorités excluent vous le
savez la thèse de l'attentât
accident ou suicide l' enquête est
toujours en cours
à bethléem dans les territoires occupés
des tirs nourris ont éclaté ce soir aux
abords de la basilique de la nativité où
quelques 200 combattants palestiniens
sont toujours assiégée pour l'instant
pas de blessé selon un policier
palestinien présent à l'intérieur du
bâtiment les forces israéliennes
encerclent donc depuis vingt jours des
palestiniens dont une trentaine de
terroristes selon elle
retranché dans le bâtiment c'est la fin
de cette édition spéciale consacrée à
l'élection présidentielle mais restez
avec nous si vous aimez la politique
juste après la météo de patrice drevet à
21h25 21h30 donc un documentaire de
patrick boitet aux marches du palais qui
retrace la campagne des différents
candidats à cette élection côté
coulisses côté média côté meeting donc
une grande soirée politique sur france 2
minutes 50 journal de la nuit jean
claude renault demain dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra ségolène royal
ministre déléguée à la famille
merci votre attention à demain